APPEARS THAT HASPELL HAS THE
VOTES TO BE CONFIRMED.
A COMMITTEE VOTE IS SET FOR
TOMORROW.
IN THE MEANTIME, ANOTHER OF THE
PRESIDENTS PICKS TO A KEY
NATIONAL SECURITY POSITION
APPEARS TO BE AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT'S DECISION TO REVERSE
COURSE ON TOUGH PENALTIES
AGAINST THE MAJOR CHINESE
TELECOM COMPANY.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS THAT
TONIGHT FROM CAPITOL HILL.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S NOMINEE TO
TRACK HER TERRORIST AND
COMMUNIST THREATS SINGLED OUT
HIGH RISK.
>> WOULD YOU RECOMMEND ANYONE IN
ANY POSITION THAT A SENSITIVE
WEATHER AND COMMERCE OR
GOVERNMENT AND CONTRACTING USE
THE PHONE?
>> KNOW I WOULD NOT.
>> THEY USE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
INFILTRATE NETWORKS AND A STEEL
AMERICAN'S PERSONAL INFORMATION.
>> CHINA USES ITS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES FOR
REASONS FOR ASPEN, ESPIONAGE.
>> WE'VE BEEN ON THE RECORD IN
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH THAT FACT.
>> HE WANTED TO SAVE VT AS PART
OF A LARGER TRADE DEAL WITH
CHINA AND THAT DREW CRITICISM
FROM OTHER LAWMAKERS.
>> DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
OVERRULE THE ADVICE AND JUDGMENT
OF THE SECURITY COMMUNITY AND
OFFER CTE A WAY TO GET BACK INTO
BUSINESS FAST?
HOW ARE YOU RAISING THESE FACTS
WITHOUT WHITE HOUSE?
>> WE ARE GARNERING THE SUPPORT
OF THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
AND REGULATORY COMMUNITY.
WE HAD MEETINGS YESTERDAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> AMERICAN JOBS AND NATIONAL
SECURITY SHOULD BE AHEAD OF
CHINESE BUSINESS INTERESTS.
>> USUALLY KEEP THE BAN ON ZTE.
IT WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT WE
SAW
SHOW CHINA WE WOULD BE TOUGH IN
MID BUSINESS AND AS SOON AS THAT
HAPPENS, THE PRESIDENT BACKS
OFF, BAD FOR AMERICAN JOBS.
>> THE RUSSIANS ARE IN MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
>> I DON'T THINK ANYONE IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY WILL
UNDERESTIMATE THE POTENTIAL OF
THE RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES.
THEIR CAPABILITY AND INTENT.
>> AND NEW WARNINGS ABOUT
SOPHISTICATED VIDEOS CALLED DEEP
FAKE.
>> THE ABILITY TO CREATE
ALTERNATIVE REALITY.
IF YOU ADD TO THAT THE SOCIAL
MEDIA, IS A PERFECT STORM OF
DISINFORMATION.
>> I THINK WE SAW THAT THE
INTENT IS THERE AND CAPABILITIES
ARE THERE.
>> A GROWING NUMBER OF FOREIGN
ADVERSARIES HAVE A CYBER
CAPABILITY TO REMOTELY ACCESS
INTELLIGENCE TARGETS AND